um so hi everybody and and welcome to
um today's um quantum colloquium
so um today it's a real pleasure to have
uh
henry in here um henry was um
got his phd from mit he spent
some time in berkeley as a postdoc uh
dennis on the faculty at university of
toronto and
he is now on his way to columbia
university
um so henry was was involved in work on
on randomness certification and then on
this on this
um really celebrated work on mip star
equal to ari which
which i'm really looking forward to
hearing about so
so henry please
well thanks umash uh yeah and thanks for
the invitation to
to speak at this colloquium um so
so today i'm going to talk about mip
star equals re
which some of you have heard about um
and this is a theorem that was proved
last year with uh my amazing
collaborators
jiang feng ji on in the tarzan toma
vidic and john wright
and one of the things that makes this
theorem
very interesting is that there are many
angles from which to
to understand it and in this talk
i'm going to discuss it through one
particular lens which is
that of proofs and proof checking
so so let me just dive into it
i'll start by defining what mip star is
this refers to a model of multiprover
interactive proofs
with entangled provers
and in this model there's a classical
polynomial time verifier
that interacts with two computationally
unbounded provers
these provers are not allowed to
communicate with each other during the
interaction
but they're allowed to share quantum
entanglement to correlate their messages
that they send back to this verifier
so that's the model and mip star
it's a complexity class and it consists
of all decision problems
that admit an interactive proof in this
model
so you know the verifier gets some input
x
um and in order to determine whether the
uh
input is in the language or not uh the
the verifier interacts with the
approvers um and at the end
if x really is in this language then
there exists a
strategy for these provers they they
choose some
quantum entangled state to share um and
they have a set of measurements that
they perform on the entangled state
such that the verifier accepts the
interaction with
high probability but on the other hand
if x is not in the language then no
matter what strategy the provers use
the verifier will reject with high
probability so this is a model that was
uh first introduced by cleve hoyer
toner and watrus back in 2004.
so that's mipstar
now what is re so re stands for
the set of recursively enumerable
decision problems
and this complexity class um is
absolutely enormous
uh i mean it really should be called
it's a computability class really
and you know it contains p n p
exponential time uh double exponential
time
you name it it contains all decidable
problems um and then some
so the complete problem for re is the
halting problem
and this is to determine which turing
machines eventually halt
and famously turing showed that the
halting problem
is undecidable so there's no algorithm
to actually solve this problem
so re is it's enormous class contains
lots of very difficult problems
and this equality between mip star
and re gives a characterization
of the complexity of entangled prover
interactive proofs
so every problem that can be decided by
an m p star protocol
can be reduced to the halting problem
this this is not so hard to show
but the reverse direction is also true
which that every problem
in re has an mip star protocol that
decides it
uh including the halting problem so
there's a there's a number of surprising
and unexpected consequences of this
equality
uh one of them is you know there's no
algorithm to approximate the maximum
success probability of
non-local games that's one
there's another consequence which is
this equality gives a negative answer to
something known as cyrilson's problem
from mathematical physics
i won't describe this
uh it also gives a negative answer in
turn to
something known as the con embedding
problem from operator algebras in pure
mathematics
and like i mentioned it means that there
is an interactive proof
for the halting problem in this model of
entangled provers
so this talk is going to focus on on
this last one
um so so i want to sort of explore what
what does it mean to to have an
interactive proof or an undecidable
problem
how is that even possible
okay so so what does it mean so
uh in this mip star protocol
the verifier is going to get as input a
description of a turing machine
so think of it as the source code of
some computer program
and the provers here you know we're
assuming that they're computationally
omniscient
they can solve undecidable problems uh
and you know in one step
so they know whether m halts or not
um uh but what the verifier wants to
i mean the verifier also wants to know
whether m halts or not um and it wants
to know if if i
if i took this turing machine and i ran
it would it eventually stop
but the problem of course is that this
turing machine might take an enormous
number of steps to run
far beyond whatever time the verifier
has
and so it the verifier wants to enlist
the help of these
provers to become convinced of whether
it halts um
so it engages in a this interactive
protocol the
the provers will you know make use of
their quantum entanglement to
you know decide what messages to send
back to the
verifier and um if m does eventually
halt
then um there is an entangled prover
strategy where
the verifier will actually actually
accept with probability one
but if m never halts then no matter what
the approver say
uh the probability that the verifier
accepts is is at most let's say one
percent
i mean this constant can be made
arbitrarily small
but it you know the important thing is
that it's bounded away from one
so so what's really remarkable is that
um the complexity of the verifier you
know how much time it takes to to
run this protocol it's polynomial in the
description length of this turing
machine
but it's independent of the running time
of the turing machine
okay so you know this turning machine
could take you know 10 lifetimes of the
universe to eventually halt
but this doesn't matter for the protocol
all that matters is
actually how many bits does it take to
describe the turing machine
and and you know at the end of this
interaction the verifier may still have
no idea
what's even a reasonable upper bound on
how long it takes
for this turing machine to halt if it
does eventually halt
okay so you know when i talk to people
about this result i've often encountered
this question of whether
does this mean quantum computers can
solve the halting problem
so i want to emphasize that this result
does not imply that
we know that quantum computers cannot
solve undecidable problems
you know classical computers can
simulate quantum computers without most
an exponential slowdown
mip-star equals re is is not about
solving the halting problem
but instead it's about efficient
verifiability
of it so you know again
you know these provers are omniscient
you know they can solve any problem they
like
but you know the challenge for them is
to for them to convince a
computationally limited verifier
of the correct answer
so you know still it's pretty
counter-intuitive that
in this mip start model which is you
know pretty well motivated and it's a
pretty reasonably defined model of
interactive proofs
that unsolvable problems like the
halting problem can be
verified so
you know this talk is going to explore
how this is possible and my goal today
is to try to shed some light on the
following questions
you know how can there be an interactive
proof for an undecidable problem
how do proofs and proof checking play
you know what role do they play in mip
star equals re
um where does the uh where does quantum
come in you know
why is this entanglement useful um so
um hopefully i'll try to give some
answers to that um and and towards the
end
if i have some time i'd like to describe
some questions
um in an area that i call
non-commutative property testing
and um these these questions are
motivated by
the phenomena that occurs within
the techniques and tools that are used
inside mip star equals re
okay so so let's get into how do you
prove that a turing machine
eventually halts
so i want to consider a slightly easier
version of the halting problem
and this is called the bounded halting
problem so here imagine that someone
walks up to you and they claim that a
turing machine m
halts in a time t so they're going to
give you a specific
time bound for you to check how do you
verify this claim
well the someone could just provide you
with an execution trace of n
so this would be a step-by-step record
of all the computations that
m takes and you can verify this by just
scanning through each of the steps
uh line by line and you verify that it's
a valid execution
trace but of course this takes at least
time t
to verify and you might as well just run
the turing machine yourself
so this doesn't seem like a very uh
efficient way of
of checking
but if you allow your verification
process to be randomized
then it's possible for someone to
provide what's called a
probabilistically checkable proof
or a pcp of the fact that
m halts in time t if if that is really
the case
and the time to verify uh a pcp
can be much smaller than um this
original time t
it can be poly logarithmic in t so an
amount that's exponentially smaller than
the original time bound
so here's the setup of a pcp
it's some string of length poly t
and we have a verifier here that runs in
time polylogarithmic and t
and the verifier will choose random
locations in this proof to
to sample and check so
the verifier will will select random
queries q1 up to qk
and um it receives proof symbols from
this long string
um say pi q1 up to pi qk
and the verifier based on its queries
and the the
proof symbols that it receives they'll
compute some function and decide whether
to accept or reject
and in this in the context of this
bounded halting problem
if m halts in time t then there is such
a proof string of polynomial and t
length that this verifier will accept
with
probability one but on the other hand if
if uh the claim is false then no matter
what proof string you write down
the verifier will accept with let's say
at most one percent probability
um so this is quite a remarkable fact
that you can check these really long
computations
using an extremely efficient verifier
that you know doesn't even have enough
time to
to read in the the whole proof um henry
are you assuming multiple approvers here
oh uh so here i'm talking about pcp so
the the proof here is just a string
uh but i'm going to connect it to the
the prover setting like in the next
slide
oh okay so you have an exponentially
long proof string okay
that's right yeah right yeah yeah the
well the proof string is exponentially
long in the running time of the verifier
yeah
so uh you know so scott brings up a good
question you know before
i was talking about um you know verifier
interacting with different provers and
now i'm talking about
verifier um sam you know looking at uh
bits from a long string what's the
connection
um well the connection is going to be as
follows so
you know the existence of this this pcp
for this bounded halting problem with
this very efficient verification
this is a consequence of uh i guess that
you could say it's the classical
precursor of mip star equals re
this is mip equals nx and this is uh
was proved nearly 30 years ago by by
fort noun lund
and so mip without the star this is
multi-prover interactive proofs
with deterministic provers or classical
provers
okay so um in this talk uh they'll be
designated
um as not having squiggly lines between
the provers so it means that they're
they're classical and nx is a complexity
class it stands for non-deterministic
exponential time
um and it uh essentially corresponds to
exponential size and p
problems um and uh it turns out that
these two complexity classes um are
equal
um and and right so so you know there's
somehow two different models of proof
checking that i've introduced here one
is uh you know this interactive proof
and one is
where a verifier is just reading bits
from a very long string
so so how do we how do we connect the
two
well let's say you had a pcp verifier so
this is the verifier well it looks at
queries locations in in this very long
string
we can convert it to an equivalent mip
verifier
with equivalent complexity so here's how
the
the transformation works so
what v prime is going to do v prime is
this verifier in this interactive proof
it's going to run the pcp verifier to
generate queries q1 up to qk
as if there was a long string out there
that instead has provers to talk to
so v prime
is going to send all of the queries
these pcp queries q1 up to qk
to the first prover and it's going to
get
some answers a1 up to ak back
and the thing to note here is that since
we're in this interactive setting
there's no guarantee
that um the this a1 up to ak corresponds
to
um uh bits of uh
uh a proof string okay
to the second prover um the verifier is
going to choose
one of the queries qi at random okay
from this list and send it to the second
approver
and it's going to receive some answer b
and the important thing here is that the
second prover has no idea what
what is the collection of queries
q1 up to qk it only sees the ith one
and once the verifier gets all the
answers back it's going to check
would the pcp verifier have accepted
the the answers of the first
prover according to these queries okay
and it's going to check that the second
prover's answer is consistent with the
first one
and the effect of all is of all of this
is that um
you know you can think of in the
following way
this first prover again you know he only
sees a single query at a time
and since we're imagining that these
provers are deterministic
this you can imagine that the all the
responses
of the second prover form a proof string
pi
okay and because we're doing a
consistency check between prover one and
prover two
um we're essentially prover one uh
has to uh just respond honestly with
uh bits from this proof string pie um
it you know it cannot change its answer
depending on what collection
of queries it gets
so you know through this transformation
you know you can argue that this
resulting mip protocol is equivalent to
the original pcp protocol
and if there was a proof string pi that
was accepted by
this top verifier v then there's some
prover strategy that's also accepted by
v prime
right they they just take that proof
string and just
reply honestly with um from it
uh and if all proofs pi are rejected by
this pcp verifier with high probability
then you can also argue that no matter
what the provers say
um they you know they get rejected with
some
at least one over k probability which
can be amplified to
um to nearly one by by repeating you
know
not too many times
okay so so the upshot of this is that
uh given you know if you know that
there's a pcp for this bounded halting
problem
there's also an mip protocol for it um
and you know here the the verifier
complexities still must depend on the
complexity of m
there's you know the verifier's run time
is poly logarithmic in in
t right but remember our eventual goal
is to somehow get this
verifier complexity to be independent of
t so how do we get there
and this is you know we're going to have
to use entanglement somehow
so you know let's let's imagine the
following situation
let's go back to the the the pcp setting
so we have a a poly t
length proof pcp proof pi okay so it's
very very long
and we have a verifier that runs in
not just logarithmic time but log log
time so
you know it's uh this proof string is
going to be doubly exponential
um long in the complexity of this this
mini verifier so so here's
some wishful thinking you know can we
somehow get this log log t complexity
verifier
to check a proof of poly t length
okay so uh it's it's not going to be
able to do it by itself
um not without some help um and you know
one of the
the barriers is that the the randomness
of this verifier
um you know since it runs in log log t
time
um it only has access to log log t bits
of randomness
so how many different locations of this
proof could it uh
individually address it's at most
logarithmic and t
and that's still a vanishingly small
fraction of this entire proof so it
you know it couldn't even flip enough
coins to you know
refer to it to every location that's
proof um
so so that's a a problem so you know you
can't
do this directly
um but what we do know is that there is
a
uh log of t complexity verifier so uh
not a mini verifier but the
the original you know verifier that you
know we just talked about
um that can check this large proof
so why don't we imagine just replacing
this uh you know the
you know we uh somehow encode
the verification procedure of this
say medium size verifier into a pcp
proof
pi prime okay and what this
smaller proof will will verify
is that the original verifier v
if it made these pcb queries using
poly log t randomness and you know if it
checked this proof
that it would have accepted on these
queries and these proof bits
so if we had such a proof then this mini
verifier could
you know using log log t time
just verify the the validity of this
proof
and thereby actually check the
correctness of this larger proof
by you know via proxy
so
you know in order for this to this
scheme to work
uh we need to assume that um uh we need
a couple of substrates to be satisfied
one is that
um this randomness q1 up to qk that's
fed into this
this intermediate verifier is actually
random
okay it's actually poly log t bits of
randomness
and this proof this smaller proof when
it gets this
uh these queries um and it um
you know perform some computation on the
these proof bits that
it's actually consistent with the the
larger top level proof up here
okay but if these two assumptions are
satisfied
then this mini verifier can like i said
it can check the validity of this top
proof
pi just by checking the smaller proof pi
prime which is
uh only of length poly log t
uh henry when you say random do you mean
like these are
uh uniform and independent marginally
they're all the same
okay uh so so in reality no they're
they're going to be correlated
um random bits um but for the purposes
of this talk i'm
just going to assume that they're
they're just uniform randomness uh but
of course they have to be correlated in
in the right way yeah good question
okay so um
so i should mention that this idea of um
you know checking a much larger proof by
verifying a verifier this is a basic
idea behind something known as pcp
composition and this was
used in in the proof of what's known as
the pcp theorem so this is not a new
idea
what we want to do is to take this pcp
composition
where we you just want to iterate this
over and over again
by you know instead of having say
a log log t verifier v mini why don't we
just
have another proof that that certifies
that this verifier would have accepted
you know this intermediate proof and so
on so you can imagine having
an even smaller verifier v micro that
that checks
uh you know this uh this third level
proof and and so on
okay so
uh you can imagine iterating the scheme
and that's that's sort of the the
high level idea of what we what we want
to do in in
mip start equals re um but again we we
still have these
these assumptions that that still need
to be satisfied one is that
the queries at all these levels are
actually chosen
um randomly and as madhu mentioned uh
you know they have to be chosen from the
correct distribution
and you have to make sure that the
proofs between all these different
levels are consistent with each other
right
that uh this proof in the middle
uh refers to proof symbols from the
the previous proof and so on i'm sorry
uh
henry um so you could also have referred
to just the randomness instead of the
query locations and then it would have
been independent random bits
is that correct or circular
couldn't you also just have referred to
the randomness that was used to
determine the query locations
and then you wouldn't have to worry
about the correlations at all
sure right yeah that's right yeah okay
yeah yeah the queries are
a deterministic function of the
randomness yeah so so
that's right you just have to make sure
that uh
that these you really have a source of
genuine random bits of enough
large enough length
okay so these two assumptions you know
you have to make sure that they're
they're satisfied and really
the main bottleneck actually is this
certifying the randomness
so um you know if we have this really
tiny verifier at the very bottom
and maybe it runs in log log log long
time t time
how can it verify that there's uh
you know this original polylog length
randomness
okay and um you know classically there's
this is why uh you can't carry out this
this recursive
um proof composition uh endlessly in the
classical setting
because it doesn't make sense to prove
that a string is
any individual string is random and you
know there's a
very famous dilbert cartoon maybe some
of you have seen this before that that
really
illustrates this point that um any given
any string you know how can you tell if
it's random or not that there's no
proof for it per se
and this is where the quantum
entanglement comes in
and this is where it will actually help
us certify that
there is a source of randomness and
using this we can actually
carry out this recursive
proof composition
okay
so this brings me to the the next part
of the talk which
i'll talk about something known as the
quantum low degree test
this is an efficient mip star protocol
for certifying entanglement
and once you're able to certify the
presence of large amounts of
entanglement very efficiently
as a byproduct you can certify the
generation of large amounts of
randomness
once you have that then you combine this
with this
i guess this cartoon picture of
recursive composition of
proofs and putting it all together
in a way that i won't describe in this
particular talk you you get the mip star
protocol for the halting problem
so maybe uh let me stop for a couple
seconds here
uh are there are there any questions
about um
what i just described um
uh henry like the the first assumption
you mentioned that there is a larger
proof
that is you know consistent with the
smaller proof i mean is that
also going to rely on the entanglement
between the provers
um
that part isn't um
i i would say that isn't the um
let's let's see
i i would view it as the the entangle
the critical point of the entanglement
was to generate the randomness
so is it isn't the first part of the
proof just referring to a
to m a turing machine and so your proof
is just a classical proof and you do a
pcp of it
so it's it's there's no entanglement
involved you mean the top level proof
yeah yeah yeah right
um i i guess so in at the end you know
when you have this
two prover protocol we're imagining that
the top level proof is really some
string that's sitting in
uh in the provers heads and you just
want to force them to
faithfully pick out symbols from it
and do computation on those symbols and
report to you
uh you know after they do all the the
proof compositions
the the result of the you know the
smallest proof which you actually have
the ability to
to access but we won't need entanglement
to
certify the existence of such a global
string
that is you know that the provers are
answering according
to so
i guess you you would need it but uh you
need it because you you need the
uh you need to to get the randomness in
order to
to be able to certify that it exists
okay
yeah henry another question
uh maybe this is um so in classical
pcbs when we think about this picture
that you've drawn
this cartoon uh all the green stuff
would have been work done by the
verifiers
is it a good abstraction to think in
this current context
that any randomness is coming from some
source but it's not
work done by the verifier right
uh that's right um so
yeah because in particular in this in
this situation
uh we don't want the verifier to be it
doesn't have enough time to even um
process those those green squares
because they're too long
so we're imagining that it's coming from
some other source
but does this source has to be something
that the
prover does not know right it can't be
just like you couldn't use a public
source of randomness or something
because the prover knew the values of
the green squares it could
provide a counterfeit proof
oh uh oh good uh so you're saying that
here the these blue boxes the proofs um
they cannot be ch
uh right they cannot be chosen uh in a
way that depends on the the randomness
so if i understand correctly you have to
not only
choose randomness but it has to be you
know
it has to be generated such that the
provers
have no access to it right
but you're also going to have the
provers generated for themselves
well i guess the important thing is it's
fine if the approvers have it but their
responses cannot depend
the the proofs must be fixed uh
independent of the randomness
and you have to assert and then you have
to certify that
okay
okay uh good so so now
um basically we want to reduce it to
this question of how do we certify large
amounts of
entanglement or randomness uh very
efficiently and
and this is uh brings us to the quantum
load degree test
so let's think about the following
system of equations so let's imagine we
have 9 boolean variables pi 1 up to pi
9. they you know they all
have our bits and these variables have
to satisfy the constraint that all rows
and all columns must sum to 0
mod 2 except for the very last column
which should sum to 1. so that's why
i've
shaded it in green
so it's easy to see that this is an
unsatisfiable system of equations
right i mean you can just sum up all the
constraints and see that you get a
contradiction
so there's no setting of zeros and ones
to these uh pi
i's that satisfy we can turn this into
uh this system of equations into an mip
protocol and this is also known as the
magic square game so how does this game
work
well the verifier is going to pick a
random equation so there's six possible
equations there's there's three
corresponding to the columns
and three corresponding to the rows
so let's call that equation e uh and
then the verifier is going to pick
from this equation a random variable so
you know let's imagine that the
verifier picks the let's say the green
column so this equation would be pi 3
plus pi
6 plus pi 9 equals 1.
and then a random variable from this
would be say pi 9.
so to prove
to prover 1 the verifier will send an
equation and to prover to
the verifier will just send this
variable let's say
pi nine prover one will respond with an
assignment to all the
variables in this equation and prover
two will respond with the
assignment to just the variable it
received
and the verifier will accept if um
the equation is satisfied by the first
approver and
the assignments are consistent between
the two provers so
their claimed assignment for pi 9
matches
so it's easy to see that classical
provers deterministic provers can
also cannot win perfectly because if
they could then this would
imply a satisfying assignment to to
all of these variables
but one of the amazing things about
quantum entanglement is that if the
approvers
use an entangled state they can actually
win this game with probability one
so what they can do is before the game
starts they prepare two epr pairs
so in total they share two qubits of
entanglement
and based on uh the questions that they
get
they can measure poly observables uh on
their qubits
um to produce answers and uh the poly
observables they
they measure uh can be you know you can
choose them from
this arrangement so so these are um
measurements that the the provers can
perform
um so for example if the second prover
gets
uh this ninth square it will perform
measure the yy
poly observable on the its two qubits
and turns out that this strategy allows
them to win with probability one
uh and uh this uh is another way to
prove bell's theorem which
uh this is famous theorem for physics
and really the the remarkable thing is
that the approvers can always win even
though there's no
satisfying assignment underlying their
responses
uh henry marius uh john has a nice
question um
in your randomness verification through
entanglement is it not destroyed
when you measure it
uh yes so
if you play a single you play this game
once
and you generate randomness then
afterwards the entanglement that was
used to generate the randomness
collapses and
you can't use it again that's right uh
okay so in this game um one observation
is that
a winning probability that's very close
to one you can think of it as a proof
that the prover responses are random
or another way to put it is that this
magic square game is an interactive
proof for randomness generation
and why do we know this well if their
proof if their responses
were not random then that would mean
that they were using a deterministic
strategy
um and we know that this can succeed
with probability at most
uh eight ninths or some value like that
right it cannot win with probability one
so winning with probability one they
necessarily have to have
uh responses with some entropy in it
and uh this this insight
has has been very useful in quantum
information theory
uh and it's led to uh in particular this
field of device independent cryptography
where you can actually use this idea to
to get untrusted quantum devices to
um to generate certified random numbers
uh for example
but we can um make an even stronger
statement about this magic square game
not only does uh winning with
probability
one imply that it's generating
generating randomness
but in fact uh if it's using a quantum
strategy
then this quantum strategy must look
like a very specific
one in particular it has to be
equivalent
to the strategy where you use two epr
pairs and
poly measurements there's you know
there's no other
strategy that it could be using and this
phenomenon is known as
rigidity of the magic square game
so you can view it as not just um
interactive proof of randomness but
interactive proof for
particular quantum properties so for
example
uh if they went with probability one
then
uh prover two's measurements
corresponding to the variables pi one
uh and pi five these observables must
anti-commute that's one deduction that
you can learn from from this interactive
proof and
you know the number of qubits of
entanglement that they use is at least
two
and since uh we have such a strong
characterization
of uh what states and measurements these
provers are using
randomness certification is just a
corollary uh you know
if they're using the strategy then we
just by calculation you know that
they're generating uniform randomness
okay so uh you know but by itself this
magic square game is not so useful for
uh randomness testing and that's because
the verifier complexity and the
randomness usage
is uh commensurate with the amount of
certified entanglement randomness you're
getting out
right so you know how much randomness
does it take to even
play the magic square game well you need
um
uh at least uh you know at least three
bits of randomness
um but the amount of randomness that
you're getting from the approvers
is is two bits so you know you're not um
making up for the amount of randomness
you're putting in
uh so what we would like is a more
robust and more efficient test for
entanglement
so uh well what we want is an
interactive proof
that you can run and it will certify t
qubits of entanglement
and ideally we would like the verifier
complexity to be much much smaller than
t
let's say poly log in t so this is the
efficiency property
and the robustness property is that any
prover strategy that succeeds with
probability
one minus epsilon must be delta of
epsilon close to
having t qubits of entanglement
so um it's uh not so
difficult uh to uh design interactive
proofs that satisfy just one of these
properties
like you can get efficient but not
robust uh
tests or you could get robust but not
efficient tests
the challenge is to really hit both
requirements at the same time
and that's what the quantum load agree
test accomplishes
it's a test for t qubits and it has this
polylog t
verifier complexity and the robustness
um it depends on epsilon and t
epsilon is how close you are to winning
with probability one
and uh it has a mild dependence on
t it's poly log t times some polynomial
in epsilon
so what this means is you get
non-trivial guarantees
as long as epsilon is at most one over
poly log t
so what is the quantum load degree test
uh i think the simplest way to explain
it is that it's really
what something called the classical low
degree test plus this magic square game
that we just saw
what is the classical low degree test
now this is something that comes from
classical complexity theory it's an
efficient and robust
interactive proof that the provers
responses are consistent with a low
degree polynomial
so at the core of this low degree test
is the following question
let's say that you're given some
function defined on
over some vector space over a finite
field so f to the m
and it you know maps points in this
vector space to elements in the finite
field
let's say that you knew that this
function when restricted to
um you know these one-dimensional
subspaces
agrees with a low-degree polynomial
okay let's say you know on most lines it
had this property
does this imply that this function f
overall is globally close
to a multivariate low degree polynomial
that that's the main question and this
this low degree test has
has been a very important uh component
of
the mip equals nx theorem the pcp
theorem
and in this field of algebraic property
testing and people studied this
um for for many many years
so how does the classical low degree
test work uh
you know it says interactive proof
again f is a finite field and let's say
d is some
degree bound let's imagine that it's
much much smaller than the size of this
finite field
what the verifier is going to do it's
going to pick a random point
in this vector space after the m and
it's going to pick a random line through
this
uh point it's going to send the
uh the line to one prover and a point
uh to the other proverb so the first
prover
should respond with a univariate degree
d polynomial
g and the idea is it should represent
the restriction of uh the you know this
global function
to this line so that's what g is
supposed to be
uh and uh the second prover is going to
respond with just a value b
and uh this verifier is going to accept
uh if
b is equal to g evaluated at the point
on this line
so in the case of classical provers this
second prover
all it gets is a single query in this
vector space and it responds
deterministically
so you can think of its responses as
being characterized by some function
f okay f defined on this vector space
and uh the the low degree test
uh tells us that if these provers pass
with high probability then we can
actually uh
characterize how close this function f
is from
uh being a low degree polynomial in fact
it's
um you know depending on how well they
pass this test that's how close
um f must be to this this polynomial
uh some polynomial p
and this is an extremely a good test
because it's efficient you know how uh
how much time does it take to conduct
this test
well it's going to be polynomial in the
dimension of this vector space and the
degree
in log f and this is exponentially
smaller
than the size of this object f that
you're characterizing i mean
remember f is a function that's defined
on you know f to the m
points and
you don't have to examine this entire
object at all the points in order to
determine
that it's globally close to a low degree
polynomial
okay so that's the the low degree test
now how do we
turn it into uh
uh this quantum load degree test well
uh the idea is that we essentially play
the low degree test in two different
bases
so um this verifier now interacting with
now entangled provers it's going to
say with probability one-third play the
classical low-degree test
in the z basis okay and the provers will
know that they're playing in the z
basis or it can play the classical
loaded
low-degree test in the x spaces
and with some uh the last probability
the verifier will relate these two bases
together
via this magic square game so
this is kind of a high level sketch of
how the
this quantum logic test works
this is an efficient test
here are the guarantees of it
suppose the quantum provers pass this
test
with probability one minus epsilon what
can we say about
um the structure of their strategy
well the the state that they share must
be close
to 2 to the m epr pairs
and their measurements must be close to
collections of polyx and polyz
observables on this state
um i'm confused about something if
you're just trying to verify
that the provers have two to the m epr
pairs then isn't the polynomial just a
constant polynomial
like what is the polynomial that you're
trying to force the provers to answer
consistently with
okay so um right so let's say that
they're playing the
the classic let's say they're they're
playing the classical literally test in
the z basis
then what they're supposed to do is
measure all of their epr pairs
uh get a a a bit string and then encode
it in a low degree extension and then uh
respond with let's say restriction of
that low degree extension to a line
okay so i just so you you think of the
string that they get by measuring
uh all uh everything as an encoding of a
low degree polynomial
of its entire truth table which they
then have to answer consistently with
that's right yep thanks henry one more
um when you say the verifier decides to
play these things in the z basis of the
x-bases
the verifier is classical the
communication is classical
what does what exactly does this mean uh
right so the verifier will tell the the
approver saying
uh now we're playing um this low degree
test in the z basis so when they measure
their epr pairs they should do it in
that basis
um and or when you tell them to do in
the x spaces they're supposed to do x
basis
and the way you check that these are
actually different bases
is via this magic square game
okay um
so uh and again you know i want to point
out that
the reason that we consider this
efficient is because how many epr pairs
are you
certifying two to the m but the time it
takes for this verifier to run this test
is only polynomial in m
okay and so
i think one way of looking at this
quantum load degree test is that this
verifier
you know it's running in polynomial and
m time it's getting
local views of these epr pairs
[Music]
and passing this test with high
probability is ensuring to the verifier
that
even though it never sees you know all
two to the m
measurement results of these epr pairs
that really there are
two to the end qubits behind the provers
responses
so the verifiers submitting a poly nbit
query it's getting a poly ambit response
but what's really going on you know
behind
the scenes is that there must be these
many many epr pairs
the approver is measuring these epr
pairs in some basis that depends on the
query they get
they get these this huge exponential
long string and they're going to
post-process it
uh into this polynomial size response to
send back to the verifier
that's the guarantee that the verifier
is getting from this interactive proof
given that you said that the provers
know which te
which of the three tests are getting i'm
confused as to how they could not always
just pass the magic square test by
setting aside some entangled qubits only
for that purpose
and then answering the z queries and the
x queries in some totally unrelated way
okay good so um when i say the magic
square test
um it's it's somehow like a magic square
game that's embedded into the
classical low-degree test questions so
they actually don't know sometimes they
don't know if they're playing the magic
square test or the the classical
low-degree test
okay so in the last like a couple
minutes uh i
i want to get into uh
something slightly different which is um
something i call non-commutative
property testing and
this is a collection of questions that i
think
come out of um
you know looking at this sort of what's
going on
really inside this proof of mip starter
equals re and this quantum load degree
test
and it seems to suggest some abstract
questions
um in in this setting so so let me
describe what i mean
so classical property testing it's it's
a very important
uh subfield of theoretical computer
science and it really emerged
um after people uh
proved the the the pcp theorem and maybe
mandu will correct me if i'm wrong but
i i think it's the development of the
subject of property testing came hand in
hand with
the study of probabilistically checkable
proofs
uh and you know property testing is
really about local to global phenomena
in
uh uh tcs and you know the general
format of the questions
is um you know if some commentary object
maybe it's a graph maybe it's a boolean
function
suppose that it locally has a property p
some fraction of the time does this
imply
that globally this object has the global
property
right so examples are you know is a
function a low degree polynomial
if you just look at small local views of
a graph and you see that it's planar
does that mean that the graph overall is
close to being a planar graph
or you know questions like this so this
is the
in the realm of classical property
testing
so in the setting um what you assume is
that
really you're looking at some fixed uh
ginormous object right maybe it's a
graph or function
um and it's a fixed object and you're
just getting local views of it
right so you can think of it as you know
there's some black box you you plug in
uh uh some input um and you you get an
output and you just want to
try to determine what's the structure of
this global object inside this
uh black box
now let's think about a sort of a new
model of property testing
so what if the outputs of this black box
are determined by quantum measurements
rather than deterministic evaluations
so you know the inputs and outputs of
this these box this box is
still classical but what's going on
inside this box might be a quantum
measurement of some sort
so in the setting let's imagine that
inside this box we can model it by
saying
that there's some dimension n
um a hilbert space that's inside and for
every possible input
there is some associated measurement
and when you put in an input uh it will
uh
do a measurement inside this box and and
produce the the output
you can also query this box in with a
sequence of points
but since measurements don't um
necessarily commute
uh the uh the distribution
of outputs you get might depend on the
order in which you query this box
okay so uh one way that you can
model it is you can say that the
probabilities of the outputs
of a sequence of inputs is given by
let's say you multiply the measurement
matrices
together in in some order and you take
the
uh the normalized frobenius norm
okay so this is one particular choice
but i think it's a nice choice
um so so this is the model
and in this model i think there can be
some very clean
property testing questions that can be
extracted from let's say mip start
equals re
where you don't have to refer to provers
or verifiers or entanglement
and as as an example you know we can
take this classical low-degree test
where you're trying to determine uh
whether a function is consistent with
the low-degree polynomial
instead of having a fixed function you
can imagine that every point there's an
associated measurement
and let's say that you knew if you took
a random line
and perform the measurements
corresponding to all the points in this
line
you get a sequence of values that is
consistent with let's say univariate
polynomial
then can you conclude that if you took
all of the points measurements together
and remember that they don't necessarily
all commute
can you say that these are all close to
some global measurement that produces a
low degree global polynomial
okay and in fact uh it
uh you know it is true that um even
though
you know these measurements don't all
commute this classical low-degree test
forces them to be consistent with a
commuting set of measurements and that's
one of the conclusions of this
classical low degree test
but there's other questions you can ask
you know you one can imagine
um non-commutative extensions of graph
property testing where
you know you have a graph every vertex
is associated with a a measurement
um and you can start to explore uh
if let's say you knew that a graph such
a non-commutative graph was
locally um k-colorable does this mean
that
all of the the points measurements are
in some sense k-colorable
you know there's also new questions that
you know aren't just strict
generalizations of the
the classical ones um
and you know let me just just end by
saying you know i think that
um you know i think this is a new model
of property testing and there's lots of
interesting questions to pursue
and questions can come from both the tcs
side as well as the operator algebra
side
um and you know there's already things
like the
the low degree test indicate that
there's lots of non-trivial things that
are going on
and so i think this is an interesting
area for exploration
okay so uh this this is the very last
slide of my talk
just to summarize uh i sort of described
a blueprint for
for verifying the halting problem by
recursively composing pcps
but uh i think the main bottleneck is
how do you certify that there's enough
randomness to
to check that all these pcps are correct
and you can
certify this randomness by performing
very efficient
uh entanglement and randomness tests
with this quantum loaded re-test
and then all the machinery that goes
into analyzing that
i think is related to this not community
property testing
um okay so with that uh thanks
uh happy to answer any questions
uh thanks uh henry that was a absolutely
brilliant talk and
uh uh you know about uh really stunning
results so
uh thanks a lot
um are there any questions um
no no questions that have been
unanswered so far but
i think if we have a minute or two if
people want to ask
so maybe can i sorry can i ask one
question so this
verification in your non-communicative
testing right and
in other area of mass this is usually
related to the kashtan property right i
mean
you have few generators and you test on
this very few generators then
something global about the whole group
is this related here
um yeah you know i was actually planning
on asking you the same
question
okay so yeah in principle um the answer
in in similar situations where i've seen
it the answer is yes
the only problem where one has to be
extremely careful
is is this normalized altoona so there
are the differences right so
so they have asked this question under
different parameters
and so this normalized altoona might
change the answer
to to whether it's exactly cast on g
property or not so ns3
that's a technical detail one has to be
i see
i i mean uh the the one thing that i
know about this
cash dan t property is that it's uh it
was useful to
construct expander graphs and
that's true but it's the same reason the
reason is that
you want to know whether a global
phenomena holds and you have
um you have few witnesses to do that
right and and for instance um in the
beginning of our theory this you know
beyond quan con embedding there are
these other nice algebras right
up in these hyper finite algebras and
that's exactly the same if
if the algebra is not very nice
then there is a test you know few
elements can tell you that something
global
is not does not happen and then
it's equivalent to one of these
definitions that's sometimes called the
spectral gap so it has a spectral gap
and it's witnessed by few
conditions is is there a name
to this phenomenon they call it the
spectral gap period
yeah it's a criterion for for
um aminability so it's in context of uh
hyperfiniteness aminability
i don't know that's okay
sure because uh i i think people have
the for on the con embedding side right
people have asked whether or not you can
have a property t
group which is uh which is stable
and i think it's that that would uh
like the kind of um stuff that henry's
talking about with uh
you have something where you do a very
efficient check
and then you have a you know that it
satisfies a global property that's like
stability
right so it's it's a very similar type
of question to ask if you could get a
counter example to con embedding that
way
and it's known um at least for the
naive type of stability right that it
that
i think it's known that they can't be
stable if i'm remembering it correctly
which hopefully i
am um so there
i think it's still an open question if
you could see something like property t
specifically in the mipster equals re
proof but it's uh there are some
obstacles to doing
to using property t to do what uh
what they've done in the mipster equals
reproof um
so if it just comes down to property t
it's it's definitely in a non-trivial
and non-trivial way
so it seems like the the panel is
beckoning to us so
strongly that the panelists are already
in a conversation so let me
let me go ahead and start introducing
the panel so that we can continue with
the
with the conversation and maybe uh